Michael how did you become involved how
did you first meet Mel on this movie or
or before no I was having lunch with
Mike Medavoy when he was an agent and
we've talking about projects and he said
why don't you come back to my office I
got a 8 page treatment from Gene Wilder
that you may like him Young Frankenstein
and I read it and I said wow this could
be something and he picked up the phone
called gene who was out of town and he
said I'll be coming in to LA I'd like to
meet you I met him and he says great I'd
like to work with you but it's going to
be up to Mel Brooks I wanted to direct
the movie and and I want him to pick the
producer that he wants so I said I met
him years ago but I doubt a feel
remember me and Mel was coming out to
beat the people at Warner Brothers for
Blazing Saddles around that time and he
was staying at the Beverly Hills Hotel
and gene had set up an ADA gene set up
the meeting I went to the Beverly Hills
Hotel now I had met him on Fire Island
in 1958 this was 14 years before I was a
kid and we used to go to over someone's
house who was had a big house with a
boat and so he used to see me then and I
knocked on the door of the belle of the
room at the Beverly Hills Hotel he opens
the door and he looks me up and down and
slams the door my face I couldn't
believe it he opens the door very
quickly and so where are you friends you
don't have a bathing suit on but she's
always seen you in a bathing and he
remembered and he said sit down
you're going to produce this movie and
and and I need a job so get a deal
because between that time you know he
made two great movies the producers in
12 Cheers
they didn't make any money but they were
great films and so he was just like
floating for like three years and then
all
sudden then one year he makes the to
highest-grossing comedies of all time I
still have the money I swear keep it on
keep it on me so that's how I became
involved then I made a deal at Columbia
to get the script made and then after
making it we have a meeting with them
they say we like it and Mel will tell
you the rest of that story his friend is
a very weird thing his friend this
Michael Medavoy was an agent at the time
yeah he wasn't he later went on to be
quite a studio executive he ran Tristar
films right Tristar Columbia so he had
three he had three clients that's all
I think he had no yet but no he was
normally was running an agency he had a
lot of clients but but he had gene
Wilder marty Feldman and Peter Boyle
right right basically oh now I found I
was lucky I found Cloris in a bar
half-shot and I really you know I was I
was drawn to her she had she had a kind
of Judith Anderson quality if you know
and and then you know Jean told me about
this Teri Garr person and we had some
film on Terry and I said she's
absolutely beautiful could she act and
Jean said Jean said who gives a [ __ ]
what he said so was true everything we
say so we uh Terry came in she read
about half a page and we both said yay
you know she is and she she immediately
it was amazing
there was a line she had in there and
then when Cloris was undoing the monster
setting him free free she was crazy
Terry was on the stairs looking down and
she said you know she said no no you
mustn't said mother Martha
you're hired you know I mean she read
that line so Terry did you know you're
gonna have to use an accent when you
audition no and then the next day I came
in and I had an accent because I was
doing a Sonny and Cher show and Cher's
hairdresser was German and she I just
copied everything she said check the hi
little part that's why didn't I know
what you said that